les unes de la presse
avec je veux dire shahida bonjour julien
bonjour d'amiens d'abord on commence par
cette guerre en ukraine ou plutôt les
coulisses du conflit vu de moscou où les
relations entre vladimir poutine et son
état-major militaire ne sont plus
vraiment au beau fixe quand même dire
qu'elles sont glaciales d'après le
washington post les conseillers
militaires du kremlin conseillerais mal
vladimir poutine parce qu'ils auraient
je cite peur de lui dire la vérité sur
les problèmes rencontrés par l'armée
russe en ukraine la maison blanche avait
au préalable annoncé des tensions que
des tensions s'étaient fait sentir entre
vladimir poutine et ses conseillers il
avait par conséquent pris des mesures je
cite extrême contre certains
responsables militaires l'article évoque
notamment des tensions entre l'homme
fort du kremlin est l'un de ses fidèles
le ministre de la défense qui aurait
fait part de ses doutes sur le
bien-fondé de l'invasion militaire en
ukraine ça c'est ce que dit damien la
presse américaine du côté de la presse
française le figaro évoque les failles
du renseignement russe en ukraine il y
aurait d'après l'article un
dysfonctionnement sur le patin le
partage d'informations entre les
différents services ce qui serait l'une
des raisons pour lesquelles l'armée
russe s'est embourbé en ukraine des
failles tellement énorme d'après le
journal qu'à certains moments je cite
les avions militaires ne savaient pas
qu'elles étaient des cibles au sol qu'il
devait bombarder preuve des tensions
dans le monde des espions russes le
patron du renseignement extérieur a été
limogé récemment mais un expert du
renseignement russes estiment que le
temps du grand ménage n'est pas encore
venu surtout surtout on entend dire
failles et des parts au sein du
renseignement ça se passe en russie mais
mais mais pas seulement il ya des
tensions en russie mais peut-être plus
étonnant côté français oui et c'est
l'opinion qui nous l'a appris hier soir
le général éric vidaud le directeur du
renseignement militaire français quitte
son poste sept mois seulement après sa
nomination paris lui reproche de ne pas
avoir suffisamment anticipé l'invasion
russe en ukraine alors que le
renseignement à l'arrêt depuis plusieurs
semaines sur une possible sur un tel
scénario le ministère des armées évoque
des briefings insuffisant et surtout un
manque de maîtrise des sujets fin de
citation voilà qui est dit en israël le
pays s'inquiète d'une nouvelle flambée
de violence on en parlait dans nos
journaux après donc trois attaques qui
ont touché la population israélienne en
moins d'une semaine les autorités
craignent en effet une réplique des
différentes attaques terroristes qui ont
frappé le pays dont deux mandic et par
l'organisation état islamique ces
derniers jours journal haaretz écrit qu'
israël se prépare à d'autres attentats
dans les prochains mois il revient sur
le déploiement de troupes
supplémentaires pour tenter de prévenir
tout acte de violence et notamment sur
les déclarations du ministre de la
défense de faire appel à plusieurs
milliers de réservistes stopper le
terrorisme c'est se doit d'être la
priorité du gouvernement de naftali
bennet écrit le jerusalem post dans son
éditorial le journal incite les
autorités à lutter contre le terrorisme
avec persévérance et surtout je cite
avec une poigne de fer cette
recrudescence d'actes terroristes a
provoqué la stupeur dans un pays où le
peuple s'est habitué à la résilience il
doit tout faire pour soutenir le
gouvernement ainsi que les forces de
sécurité mais alors comment cette vague
d'attentats en israël est perçue en
france eh bien elle inquiète évidemment
parce qu'un regain de tension de
violence où qu'ils soient et
principalement en israël peut avoir de
lourdes conséquences écrit la croix
après un temps d'accalmie ces attentats
commis par des palestiniens et des
arabes israéliens replongent le pays
dans un conflit que le journal explique
comme un conflit qu'elles aujourd'hui le
israël avait presque oublié le conflit
israélo palestinien que les autorités
pensaient donc terminée notamment
surtout après les accords d'abraham
signée fin 2020 je le rappelle les
accords d'abraham c'est une alliance
politique et militaire inédite entre
israël et plusieurs pays arabes et bien
selon le journal la croix il ne suffit
pas de tourner le dos et faire comme si
le conflit israélo-palestinien
n'existait pas mais bien signer il faut
signer un accord de paix avec les
palestiniens on parle de terrorisme en
france justement le procès des attentats
du 13 novembre se poursuit procès-fleuve
étendu sur neuf mois et avec qui hier à
la barre le principal accusé salle
abdeslam qui pour l'une des premières
fois s'est exprimé sur cette nuit
fatidique oui le seul survivant du
commando mortifère a beaucoup joué au
chat et à la souris depuis le début de
ce procès qui a débuté en septembre
dernier entre dialogues et silence
obstiné écrit le monde sa la abdeslam a
cette fois décidé de raconter sa version
des faits de ce qu'il s'est passé cette
nuit il a fallu deux heures de silence
avant qu'ils ne commencent à témoigner
il voulait pas parler votre exactement
on le doit gras on doit ce témoignage
grâce à l'une des avocats de la partie
civile qui semble avoir tissé un lien
avec le principal accusé est ce qu'on
apprend et bien ces cadets cela m'aurait
volontairement décidé donc vous l'aviez
dit de ne pas actionner sa ceinture
d'explosifs qui avaient été retrouvés
dans une poubelle de la banlieue
parisienne alors qu'il avait jusque là
toujours dit aux enquêteurs que cette
ceinture ne fonctionnait pas au moment
voulu mais vous allez voir et ça c'est
très intéressant qu une même scène peut
être perçue complètement différemment
par deux chroniqueurs judiciaires
libération retient n'ont pas cette
information de la ceinture d'explosifs
mais là ce qu'on pourrait appeler la
manipulation orchestrée par salah
abdeslam il prend du plaisir à garder le
silence et ça c'est la marque de lâcheté
des terroristes déclare l'avocat général
cité par le journal et ce ne sont pas
les quelques informations ou témoignage
sur sa vie personnelle qui auront
convaincu le chroniqueur judiciaire
l'avocat général et les parties civiles
qui ont tout de même donc réussi avec
leur talent à à le faire parler avant de
se quitter on termine avec cette
information de la nuit bruce willis
france sa retraite pour raisons de santé
oui l'acteur de 67 ans serait se retire
après avoir appris qu'il s'ouvrait
d'aphasie un trouble du langage causés
par des lésions cérébrales nous apprend
le site américain variéty cette retraite
forcée mesfin quasiment 40 ans de
carrière ininterrompue surtout dans des
films d'action marquée par des rôles
iconiques comme celui de john mcclane
dans la saga die hard peut-être que ça
veut dire à quelque chose cette annonce
a provoqué la stupeur et même j'ai envie
de dire la tristesse à la rédaction du
guardian bruce willis je cite c'est est
l'archétype de la masculinité gonflé à
la super testostérone et même la preuve
qu'on pouvait avoir du style en portant
un gilet bruce willis qui s'en va c'est
comme voir une star du sport se blesser
gravement écrit le journal au pire ouah
son snack favori retirer son sandwich
préféré bref conclut le journal c'est la
fin d'une époque merci beaucoup j'ai
marché